♪
>>> ALL RIGHT.
HOW WE DOING, EVERYBODY?
TONIGHT IS GAME ONE OF THE
STANLEY CUP FINALS.
NOW, YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING
WHERE GREG IS.
GREG IS ON A FLIGHT TO BOSTON TO
WATCH GAME SIX OF THE NBA FINALS
IN PERSON.
GREG DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
HOCKEY.
I PERSONALLY ALSO DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT HOCKEY, THAT'S
WHY WE'RE BRINGING IN A GOOD
FRIEND OF MINE, MICHAEL RIDDER
TO DISCUSS HOCKEY.
I HATE TO GIVE HIM CREDIT, BUT
HE'S A GURU.
I'M HEARING, SOURCES INDICATE
YOU HAVE SIX BETS FOR US TONIGHT
THAT YOU LOVE.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
SIX BETS.
I GOT THREE FOR THE WHOLE
SERIES.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO TONIGHT'S
GAME.
I'VE BEEN DEPRIVED OF HOCKEY FOR
FIVE DAYS, I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO SIT DOWN AND WATCH ANYTHING,
AND WE GET TO DO THAT TONIGHT.
WE HAVE SIX BETS.
SAM, IF YOU'RE READY, I'M READY
TO START US OFF NOW.
I'M READY TO GIVE PEOPLE A LOCK.
>> GO.
>> DO IT?
>> LET IT FLY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> SEE IF YOU CAN SEE THIS.
THIS IS THE FIRST BET THAT WE
LOVE.
NATHAN McKINNEN, 2 1/2 SERIES
GOALS.
WE LIKE THE OVER.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHY THIS IS
2 1/2.
HE COULD SCORE A HAT TRICK
TONIGHT AND THIS WILL CATCH.
HE IS, IN MY OPINION, THERE'S A
1A AND 1B IN HOCKEY.
CONNER
CONNOR McDAVID GETS CALLED THE
BEST PLAYER IN HOCKEY ALL TIME,
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE.
THE FACT THAT DRAFTKINGS IS
HANGING 2.5 -- I STARTED MAKING
THIS SIGN AND FORGOT TO WRITE
THE ODDS DOWN THERE.
IT'S MINUS 115.
THAT STUFF HAPPENS.
THE FIRST LOCK OF THE SERIES,
MINUS 2.5 OVER FOR NATHAN
MACKINNON.
I LOVE NATE DOG.
MY SECOND BET --
>> CAN I COMMENT ON THAT PICK
FIRST?
DO
>> DO YOU WANT TO?
>> YEAH.
OBVIOUSLY I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT HOCKEY, THAT'S WHY RITTER
IS OUR HOCKEY GURU.
THE NATHAN MACKINNON GOAL
AGAINST THE BLUES WHERE HE WENT
SIDE TO SIDE AND JUST RACED
THROUGH LIKE SEVEN DUDES WAS THE
MOST ELECTRIC THING I'VE SEEN IN
MY LIFE.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A FUN BET.
I LOVE THAT FOR YOU, RITTER.
>> THAT'S THE BEST GOAL I'VE
SEEN IN PERSON.
I WAS AT THAT GAME.
WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT THAT
LATER.
THAT WAS HIS THIRD GOAL OF THE
GAME.
THAT'S ALL WE NEED.
>> SEE IF WE CAN CASH THIS
TONIGHT.
>> YOU COULD CASH THIS TONIGHT.
EXACTLY.
I LOVE IT.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HANG YOU UP
TOO MUCH.
SECOND BET.
>> SECOND BET.
THE NEXT BET WILL BE A LITTLE
CONTROVERSIAL BECAUSE I HYPED UP
NATHAN MACKINNON.
THE MVP OF THE PLAYOFFS, DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT AWARD IS CALLED?
LITTLE QUIZ FOR YOU.
>> I DO BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
OUTLINE OF THE SHOW, AND IT SAID
THE NAME OF THE TROPHY.
I DO KNOW THAT.
OTHERWISE -- EH, I THINK I WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN IT REGARDLESS.
>> I THINK YOU COULD HAVE.
>> CAN I FLIP IT ON YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
>> WHO IS CONN SMYTHE?
TELL ME A FUN FACT ABOUT CONN
SMYTHE.
CAN YOU DO IT?
FRAUD.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
THIS IS A HOLE IN MY HOCKEY
KNOWLEDGE IS NOT BEING ABLE TO
TELL YOU WHO CONN SMYTHE IS, WHO
LADY BING IS, WHO THE HART
TROPHY IS NAMED AFTER.
I DON'T KNOW THOSE THINGS.
WE'RE TALKING CONN SMYTHE.
I HAVE A BET.
MY BET IS THE TAMPA BAY GOALIE,
AN
ANDREI VASILEVSKIY, HE HAS THE
FOURTH BEST GUYS TO WIN THE CONN
SMYTHE.
NOW NIKITA KUCHEROV IS ALSO AT
PLUS 400.
IF THE LIGHTNING ARE GOING TO
WIN, THEY'RE GOING TO WIN
BECAUSE OF THEIR GOALTENDER
BECAUSE HE'S THE BEST GOALTENDER
IN THE WORLD.
HE'S THE BEST GOALTENDER THE
AVALANCHE HAVE SEEN SO FAR.
I THINK THE AVS WILL STRUGGLE
WITH HIM.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT CONN
SMYTHE, IT'S ALMOST ALWAYS -- I
DON'T THINK THIS IS AN AWARD
WHERE SOMEBODY COMES OUT OF
NOWHERE TO WIN.
IT'S A MRAPLAYOFF AWARD.
THIS IS A RESUME OF THESE THREE
SERIES BEFORE THIS, AND ANDREI
VASILEVSKIY IS THE REASON WHY
THE LIGHTNING ARE HERE.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO WIN THE
STANLEY CUP, AND YOU NEED A COB
SMYTHE BET, IT MAKES ALL THE
SENSE IN THE WORLD TO HAVE
ANDREI VASILEVSKIY AS YOUR PICK.
>> I'M GOING TO CHIME IN.
I'M COMMENTING ON IT BECAUSE I
HAVE TO SAY, MY FAVORITE PART
ABOUT DOING THESE SHOWS IS THE
CHAT THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
I'M READING COMMENTS IN THE CHAT
RIGHT NOW.
MY FAVORITE THING IS WHILE YOU
ARE TALKING, MICHAEL UNDERSCORE
STEIN JUST DROPPED LIKE EIGHT
THUMBS DOWN.
HATED THE PICK.
>> WOW.
>> THAT'S GOOD ENERGY.
HATED THE PICK.
RYAN, THIS IS A GOOD TAKE FROM
RYAN.
SMYTHE NOT BEING PRONOUNCED LIKE
SMITH IS CRIMINAL.
YOUR TAKE ON THAT TAKE?
>> IT'S PROBABLY CANADIAN.
YOU KNOW, THEY THROW Us AND Es
IN CRAP LIKE THAT.
PROBABLY, SHOULDN'T CURSE.
IT MAKES SENSE --
>> CRAP IS NOT A CURSE WORD.
YOU'RE GOOD.
>> COOL.
CONN S SMITH JUST SOUNDS WEIRD.
>> THEY WENT TO COLLEGE WITH
CONNIE SMITH AT SLOAN-KETTERING.
THIRD BET, GO.
>> THIRD BET.
THE THIRD BET FOR THE SERIES IS
THE SERIES TO GO SEVEN GAMES AT
PLUS 210.
I THINK THIS SERIES IS GOING
SEVEN GAMES.
I AM BETTING IT TO GO SEVEN
GAMES.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT THE SERIES AND SAYING
THE AVALANCHE ARE A WAGON.
THEY ARE.
THE LIGHTNING AND WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE THIS POSTSEASON SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
AS WE GO INTO THE FINAL ROUND.
THEY TOOK THE -- THE TORONTO
MAPLE LEAFS TO SEVEN GAMES, WHO
ARE ARGUABLY ONE OF THE BETTER
TEAMS THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE
YEAR, AND THEY SLIPPED UP, OF
COURSE, IN CLASSIC MAPLE LEAFS
FASHION IN THE FIRST ROUND IN
THE SEVENTH GAME.
THE LIGHTNING SWEPT THE
PRESIDENT'S TROPHY WINNING
FLORIDA PANTHERS, WHICH WAS
AMAZING.
NO ONE THOUGHT THAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
YOU MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT THE
LIGHTNING WOULD WIN THAT SERIES,
BUT NO ONE THOUGHT THEY WOULD
SWEEP THEM.
AND THEY WON FOUR STRAIGHT
AGAINST THE NEW YORK RANGERS
AGAINST THE SECOND BEST
GOALTENDER IN THE WORLD.
THIS TEAM IS REALLY EFFING GOOD.
THEY'RE AWESOME.
I THINK WE GET SO TIED UP WITH
COLORADO AND COLORADO IS
INCREDIBLE.
THEY HAVE A BIT MORE STAR POWER,
BUT I THINK THAT THIS SERIES IS
GOING SEVEN.
I ALSO THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
GREAT FOR HOCKEY THAT THIS GOES
SEVEN.
THE NBA FINALS ARE ABOUT TO WRAP
UP.
THE NBA FINALS ACTUALLY WRAP UP
TOMORROW, ON THURSDAY, WHEN THE
WARRIORS WILL WIN THE NBA
FINALS.
>> GROW UP, PETER PAN.
>> THAT'S ALL WE'LL HAVE.
>> I'M JUST STATING FACTS.
>> GROW UP, DUDE.
>> ALL WE'LL HAVE IS HOCKEY,
BASEBALL.
WE NEED THIS TO GO SEVEN, IT
WILL GO SEVEN PLUS 210.
>> THE CHAT IS REALLY ROLLING
NOW.
LIKE I SAID, GET IN THIS CHAT.
THIS IS WHERE VIBES ARE MADE.
SO, MICHAEL STEIN, YOUR BIGGEST
HATER, MIGHT HAVE TO HAVE A ONE
V ONE WITH YOU AND MIKE STEIN.
HE SAID HE HATED THE PICK
BECAUSE HE'S AN AVS FAN.
JOEL CRESPO SAYS SAY POOP
INSTEAD.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO SAY CRAP,
JUST SAY POOP.
GOOD TAKE.
>> YEP.
>> MAPLE LEAFS ALWAYS CHOKE.
I KNOW THAT.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
GREAT COMMENT AND AVATAR.
YEAH.
FAV SAYS THIS RITTER GUY HAS
GOOD TAKES.
QUESTIONABLE TAKES ON MY END.
FOURTH BET?
FOUR?
>> FOURTH BET?
OKAY.
THOSE WERE OUR SERIES BETS.
NOW INTO GAME ONE --
>> ACTUALLY, LET'S DO THE FIFTH
BET, AND THEN DO THE FOURTH BET.
WE ARRANGE YOUR PAPERWORK.
>> ARE YOU SURE?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
>> FIFTH BET?
OKAY.
THE FIFTH BET --
>> I HAVE TO KEEP YOU ON YOUR
TOES.
>> THAT'S FAIR.
I GOT THEM LINED UP.
THEY'RE ALL SITTING ON THE DESK.
>> REARRANGE.
>> MICHAEL STEIN, I APOLOGIZE IN
ADVANCE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A ROUGH
SEASON.
LIGHTNING MONEYLINE PLUS 140 IS
NOW THE FOURTH BET OF THE NIGHT.
THIS IS OUR GAME ONE PICK.
I'M ROLLING WITH THE LIGHTNING.
THE AVS HAVE NOT PLAYED HOCKEY
SINCE THE COOLIDGE
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY'VE BEEN SITTING ON THEIR
BUMS FOR A WHILE.
I LOVE THE LIGHTNING TONIGHT.
THIS IS A CLASSIC TEAM PLAYING
WITH EXPERIENCE, FOR THE
AVALANCHE, THIS IS THEIR FIRST
CUP FINAL SINCE THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, YEAH, 2001.
THEY HAVE NOT MADE IT PAST THE
SECOND ROUND OF THE PLAYOFFS
SINCE THEN.
THIS IS THEIR FIRST TIME.
THEY'RE ROLLING, PLAYING VERY
WELL.
BUT THE LIGHTNING ARE BUILT FOR
THIS SITUATION, AND THEY HAVE
THE BEST PLAYER IN THE SERIES IN
MY OPINION, WHICH WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE -- YOU TOTALLY THREW THIS
OFF MIXING UP THE ORDER.
>> GOOD.
GOOD.
I HAD TO HIT IT OFF BIGFOOT.
>> FRANKENSTEIN'S FAT FOOT.
SHOUT OUT --
>> I MESSED IT UP.
>> YEAH.
YOU DID.
RILEY STEINER -- NOT MIKE
STEINER -- MIKE STEINER IS MY
BIGGEST HATER IN THE APP, WHICH
I APPRECIATE.
HE'S AN AVS FAN.
RILEY STEINER IS ALSO ON MY
SIDE.
SO EVERYONE IN THE APP IS RIDING
WITH THE LIGHTNING TONIGHT.
I DID MY HANDICAPPING, I SAID I
HAVE TO GO WITH THE LIGHTNING
TONIGHT.
THAT'S MY FOURTH PICK OF THE
NIGHT.
TRANSLATING INTO MY FIFTH
FAVORITE PICK OF THE NIGHT --
>> RITTER -- NOPE.
NOPE.
I AM THE CONDUCTOR OF THE SHOW.
I'M THE GOLDEN GOD.
LET ME DO MY THING, DUDE.
JUST KIDDING.
I DO -- THERE'S A COMMENT.
A COMMENT I WANT TO GET TO.
I LOVE THE CHAT.
BIG CHAT GUY.
SOMEONE JUST ASKED WHO'S GOING
TO SCORE TONIGHT?
DO ANY OF YOUR BETS HAVE A
SCORER PICK?
IF NOT, YOU'LL HAVE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION AND GIVE A SCORE
PICK RIGHT NOW.
>> I WILL GIVE A SCORER'S PICK.
I DON'T HAVE THAT AS ONE OF THE
SIX.
I'M GOING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
WE CAN DO A LITTLE -- IF YOU
HAVE A GOAL SCORER PROP, DROP IT
IN THE CHAT RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD LOVE TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> THAT WAS A GOOD DEFLECTION ON
YOUR END.
GOOD DEFLECTION TO AVOID GIVING
A PICK.
PUT IT ON THE AUDIENCE.
FAV ASKS TAKES ON THE COOLIDGE
ADMINISTRATION, WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THE END OF THAT.
AND ANOTHER SAID WE WON'T TALK
ABOUT THE REST.
I'M NOT EQUIPPED TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION.
ONLY RITTER CAN DO THAT.
GIVE ME YOUR FIFTH BET THAT WAS
YOUR FOURTH BET.
>> MY FIFTH BET IS ANDREI
VASILEVSKIY OVER 32.5 SAVES.
I DIDN'T WANT TO RIGT WRITE
VASILEVSKIY, I JUST HAVE VASI.
SO OVER 32.5 SAVES.
THAT NUMBER HAS JUMPED.
IT MIGHT BE 33 AT DRAFTKINGS
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S GOING UP.
A GREAT BET.
IF IT'S AT 33 RIGHT NOW, YOU CAN
CHECK THAT.
STILL TAKE IT.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE,
LIKE, 36 SAVES TONIGHT, THAT'S
WHAT I'M THINKING.
THE AVALANCHE, THEY AVERAGE
AROUND 36 SHOTS ON GOAL A GAME.
AND I THINK VASILEVSKIY IS GOOD
ENOUGH TO STOP ALL OF THOSE.
IF YOU WANT TO BET A SHUTOUT
TONIGHT, YOU CAN.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
BUT ANDREI VASILEVSKIY, LIKE I
SAID, THE BEST GOALTENDER IN THE
WORLD.
I'M BETTING HIM TO WIN THE CONN
SMYTHE, AND I THINK 32.5 IS TOO
LOW.
THE AVALANCHE ARE AN AVALANCHE
OF OFFENSE AND THEY'LL BE
PEPPERING THEM ALL NIGHT.
THE ONLY THING THAT WORRIES ME A
LITTLE BIT, IN THE PREVIOUS
SERIES, THEY PLAYED TEAMS THAT
ARE NOT MKNOWN FOR PLAYING
DEFENSE.
THAT'S NOT THE SAME FOR THE
LIGHTNING.
THEY HAVE VICTOR HEDMAN.
HE IS OUTSTANDING.
HE WILL BE A BIG PART IF THE
LIGHTNING CAN WIN THIS.
GOING BACK TO THE LIGHTNING
MONEYLINE PICK, WHY I WANTED TO
TAKE THAT, I'LL BRING THIS BACK
QUICKLY, IF THE GAME IS GOING TO
BE A TRACK MEET, THE AVS WILL
WIN EVERY GAME.
YOU CANNOT WIN TRACK MEETS
AGAINST THE AVS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE THINKING ABOUT
THE OF/UNDER IN THIS GAME.
IF YOU LIKE THE LIGHTNING, YOU
PROBABLY LIKE THE UNDER.
IF YOU LIKE THE AVS, YOU
DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE ANDREI
VASILEVSKIY IS MAKING OVER 32.5
SAVES.
>> I'M GOING BACK TO THE CHAT.
I LOVE THE CHAT.
THIS IS THE MOST FUN PART THAT
WE GET TO TALK STRAIGHT TO THE
PEO
PEOPLE.
>> HOW ARE THE LIGHTNING GOING
TO WIN WHEN THEY'RE GOING TO GET
OUTSHOT 3-1.
STOP HYPING THE GOALIE.
I LIKE THE VASI SAVES PICK
TONIGHT, THOUGH.
RESPECT.
6-
6-3 AVS.
I FEEL YOU AGREE WITH SOME OF
THAT, RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SHOUT OUT FOR PUTTING RESPECT.
IT'S ALWAYS WHEN PEOPLE SHIT ON
YOUR PICK BUT SAY RESPECT.
>> SO YOU WEREN'T COMFORTABLE
WHEN YOU SAID CRAP BUT DROP AN
"S" BOMB WHEN CHILDREN ARE
WATCHING?
>> YOU HAVE TO BE 21 TO BET.
>> YOU FREAKED OUT.
>> I'M NERVOUS.
I'M SWEATING LIKE CRAZY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S SOME -- SHOT ON GOAL IN
THE FIRST MINUTE, MINUS 145.
THERE'S -- THE NAME IS TOUGH.
I'M NOT GOING TO TRY.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE AVS ARE
MISSING THREE KEY PIECES,
MACKINNON FIRST GOAL.
KIDS ARE CRYING NEAR RYAN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU ACT
LIKE THIS ON A SHOW.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> LAST BET.
LAST BET.
HOUSE.
>> THE FINAL BET, THE SIXTH BET
THAT WE LOVE TONIGHT IS -- YOU
KNEW IT WAS COMING.
THE GIFT.
GOAL IN FIRST TEN.
IT'S PLUS 100 AT DRAFT KINGS
TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE BEST BET IN SPORTS.
WE KNOW WHY WE LOVE THIS BET.
IT'S THE BEST BET IN SPORTS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A COSTUME THAT
GOES WITH IT.
THE LAST TIME WE WORE THIS, IT
CASHED.
THAT GAME WAS IN COLORADO.
IT CASHED.
SO WE'RE TAKING --
>> WHAT DOES THE CARD SAY?
>> IT SAYS SOMETHING.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT IT SAYS.
>> LET'S SEE IT.
SAY IT OUT LOUD.
WHY CAN'T YOU SAY IT?
>> IT SAYS TWO WOMO WOMEN FROM .
>> AND YOU WORE THAT OUT IN
PUBLIC?
>> I WORE IT OUT IN PUBLIC.
I WORE IT TO WATCH A HOCKEY
GAME.
PEOPLE LOVED IT.
I DRANK A FEW BEERS IN IT.
I THINK I MIGHT JUST WEAR IT FOR
THE REST OF THE SHOW.
IT'S PRETTY COMFORTABLE.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ROLLING
WITH TONIGHT AS OUR SIXTH BET.
SOMEBODY SAID NATHAN MACKINNON
FIRST GOAL?
I KIND OF LIKE THAT.
I THINK THE LIGHTNING WILL SCORE
THE FIRST GOAL BECAUSE I DON'T
REALLY LIKE DARCY KUEMPER.
I WAS AT THAT AVS GAME BECAUSE I
AM A BLUES FAN.
THE LIGHTNING ARE WAY BETTER
THAN THE BLUES.
I THINK THE LIGHTNING WILL SCORE
FIRST.
THEY'LL SCORE IN THE FIRST TEN
MINUTES, WE'LL CASH THE GIFT AND
I'LL WEAR MY COSTUME WHILE I'M
AT MY PARENTS HOUSE TONIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU DO THAT, YOU NEED
SOMEONE TO TAKE A PICTURE OF IT
AND DROP IT IN THE COMMUNITY
STREAM IN THE APP SO EVERYONE
CAN ROAST YOU.
I'M HEARING -- SOURCES ARE
INDICATING THAT MACKINNON FIRST
GOAL IS 10-1.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
RITTER, I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
I'VE GOT A BONE TO PICK WITH
YOU.
THE CHAT DOES, TOO.
YOU'RE GETTING OBLITERATED RIGHT
NOW.
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
BUT YOU JUST GAVE OUT SIX BETS
FOR THE STANLEY CUP FINALS, AND
YOU DID NOT GIVE OUT ONE BET FOR
WHO IS GOING TO WIN THE SERIES.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THAT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
I WANT TO MOVE ON, BUT I WILL
GIVE YOU 12 SECONDS TO DEFEND
YOURSELF.
>> HONESTLY, I'M JUST EXCITED
ABOUT IT GOING SEVEN.
I HAVE A LEAN, I MIGHT GIVE THAT
OUT IN A SECOND.
HAND UP, BOTH HANDS UP LIKE
THIS -- I FORGOT.
>> WORRIED ABOUT YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S PULL UP SOME TWEETS HERE.
I LOVE TO HEAR WHAT PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ON THE
TWITTE
TWITTERSPHERE.
I WILL PULL UP A TWEET RIGHT NOW
FOR US TO REACT TO.
THIS IS PRETTY MUCH FROM
POOFASHUR, HOPE I DID THAT
RIGHT.
TALKING ABOUT HOW THE AVS PLAYED
A POV ERTY GOALIE THE ENTIRE
SEASON AND NOW GOING AGAINST
VASI, AND NOW THEY'RE IN
TROUBLE.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THAT?
HAVE THEY SKATED AROUND PLAYING
AGAINST POVERTY GOALIES AND ARE
NOW IN TROUBLE AGAINST VASI?
>> SO, I WOULD SAY THAT HAS SOME
TRUTH TO IT.
THEY PLAYED NASHVILLE IN THE
FIRST ROUND.
NASHVILLE WAS KIND OF A TOUGH
TEAM, BUT NOT REALLY.
REALLY THE BEST GOALTENDER THEY
FACED WAS JORDAN BINNINGTON.
HE WAS OUTSTANDING AGAINST THEM,
THEN THEY PLAYED BILLY WHO P
TURNED IT ON AT THE END OF THAT
SERIES.
THEY PLAYED ARGUABLY THE WORST
GOALTENDER IN THE PLAYOFFS IN
MAKE SMITH, AND IT SHOWS BECAUSE
THEY SWEPT HIM.
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE.
IF THE LIGHTNING ARE GOING TO
STEAL ONE, IT WILL BE THE FIRST
GAME.
THE AVALANCHE WILL BE STUNNED
WHEN THEY GO FROM SWISS CHEESE
MIKE SMITH TO BRICK WALL MIKE
VASILEVSKIY.
>> MIKE SMYTHE.
>> GOOD CALL.
I DO REALLY LIKE THAT TAKE.
SIRI IS HOPPING ON TO SAY
SOMETHING.
THAT'S A GREAT TWEET FOR SURE.
>> CAN YOU ASK SIRI WHO SHE
THINKS WILL WIN THE STANLEY CUP
FINALS?
>> YEAH.
GET A THIRD PERSON HERE.
IT'S GREAT.
HOW DO I DO THAT?
SIRI, WHO DO YOU THINK WILL WIN
THE STANLEY CUP FINAL?
>> THOSE IN THE KNOW SAY THE
AVALANCHE WILL DEFEAT THE
LIGHTNING BY 1 1/2 GOALS.
>> WHAT?
>> OH!
MINUS 1 --
>> SERIOUSLY?
>> PEOPLE COME ON AND THEY DO
SHOWS AND THEY SAY IT'S NOT
PLANNED, BUT IT'S ACTUALLY
PLANNED.
THAT WAS NOT PLANNED.
THE FACT THAT SIRI IS GIVING OUT
AVS AT MINUS 1.5, THAT'S WILD.
CAN WE CLIP THAT OR AT LEAST --
THAT'S A POST, RIGHT?
AVS MINUS 1.5 FROM SIRI,
ELECTRIC.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S PULL UP ONE MORE TWEET.
LET'S PULL UP ONE MORE TWEET
THAT I SAW THAT WAS INTERESTING.
I WANTED YOUR TAKE ON IT,
RITTER.
CAN WE GET IT UP?
THERE IT IS.
ALL RIGHT.
MY FIRST TAKE WHEN SEEING THIS
TWEET IS CAKEMAKER -- CAN'T BE
RIGHT.
DAN ROSEN, I'M ASSUMING A TYPO,
I'LL DEFER TO YOU.
BUT PRETTY MUCH -- HE GAVE A
QUOTE.
HE SAID THEY'RE A TEAM LOOKING
TO BECOME A DYNASTY, THEM BEING
THE LIGHTNING, AND WE'RE A TEAM
LOOKING TO START A LEGACY.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO CALL HIM
CAKEMAKER NOW.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
QUOTE AND WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS
ON DAN ROSEN'S TYPO?
>> DAN ROSEN'S TYPO IS
EGREGIOUS, I GUESS IS THE BEST
WORD -- WORST WORD TO DESCRIBE
IT.
IT'S CALE MAKAR.
I KNOW IT'S A DIFFERENT FOOD
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
CALE MAKAR, YOU CAN'T MESS HIM
UP.
HE'S THE BEST DEFENSEMAN IN THE
NHL.
HE'S AMAZING.
AS FAR AS THE QUOTE GOES, A
GREAT QUOTE, BUT TALK IS CHEAP.
TALK IS CHEAP.
YOU CAN SAY ALL THIS STUFF,
BULLETIN BOARD MATERIAL.
SURE, IF YOU WANT TO FIRE UP THE
TEAM, YOU MIGHT HAVE ALSO FIRED
UP THE LIGHTNING, THE
BACK-TO-BACK DEFENDING STANLEY
CUP CHAMPIONS.
TALK IS CHEAP.
YOU GAVE BULLETIN BOARD MATERIAL
TO TAMPA.
YEAH.
CAKEMAKER -- THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ROLLING WITH NOW?
>> PRETTY GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
I WAS GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT SECTION AND JUST, LIKE,
BADGER YOU FOR YOUR SERIES
PICKS.
BUT I'VE BEEN IN THE LAB.
I FOUND TWO MORE TWEETS THAT ARE
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
I WILL TRY TO PULL THEM UP.
LET'S SEE IF WE GOT THEM UP.
THIS ONE COMES FROM MIKE RITTER,
AND IT SAYS SPEAKING OF BULLETIN
BOARD MATERIAL, THE AVS SUCK,
YO.
INTERESTING TWEET.
CREDIT TO YOU FOR GETTING IN AND
OUT AND NOT BURYING THE LEAD.
THAT'S ONE TWEET.
I GOT A SECOND ONE THAT I'LL TRY
TO PULL UP HERE.
NEW TO HOSTING.
AVS ARE FRAUDS.
AVS IN THE STANLEY CUP FINALS,
FAVORED TO WINMENT YOU HAVE
GIVEN THEM SOME BULLETIN BOARD
MATERIAL AND EXPOSED YOURSELF AS
A FRAUD YOURSELF.
DEFEND YOURSELF.
>> YEAH.
THOSE WERE NOT PHOTO SHOPPED,
THOSE ARE ACTUALLY MY TWEETS?
>> I CANNOT CONFIRM NOR DENY.
>> GOT YOU.
>> NO.
THOSE ARE MY TWEETS.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO REVEAL
MYSELF AS A ST. LOUIS BLUES FAN,
SO I'M PROBABLY BIASED HERE.
I THINK THE AVS SUCK TWEET IS
WHEN THEY ALMOST BLEW A GIANT
GOAL LEAD IN AN 8-6 GAME AGAINST
MIKE SMITH AND AN OILERS TEAM
THAT WASN'T ANY GOOD.
THEY SWEPT THEM, I GET IT.
THE AVS ARE FRAUDS, I THINK THAT
CAME AFTER MY TEAM BEAT THEM AT
HOME TWICE.
YEAH, WE LOST THE SERIES, MIKE
STEIN IS PROBABLY LIKE THIS
MAKES MUCH MORE SENSE NOW.
>> I NEED MIKE STEIN IN THE
COMMENTS.
>> GET HIM IN.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO REVEAL MY
LEAN FOR THIS STANLEY CUP FINAL.
I'M PICKING THE TAMPA BAY
LIGHTNING TO WIN THE STANLEY CUP
FINALS.
I'M TAKING THE PLUS MONEY.
GOING FOR THE THREE-PEAT.
PAT MAROON WILL WIN FOUR STANLEY
CUPS IN A ROW.
THE AVS ARE FRAUDS.
I'LL SAY IT.
>> DOUBLING DOWN.
YOU'RE GOING AGAINST SE SIRI?
>> SIRI NEVER WATCH AD HOCKEY
GAME IN HER LIFE.
>> NOT A BAD TAKE.
>> RITTER, SOMEONE IN THE
COMMENTS -- ALL RIGHT.
YOU LIKE THE LIGHTNING.
AGAIN, I KNOW WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
MOVE ON.
I LIKE TO CHAT.
I'M A CHAT GUY.
I WANT TO BE IN THE CHAT.
SOMEONE SAYS MAC KINNON TO SCORE
15 PLUS POINTS FOR THE SERIES,
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
MACKINNON POINTS IN THE SERIES
OR MARCUS SMART -- I'M MAKING UP
A BET ON THE FLY.
MARCUS SMART POINTS TOMORROW.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING WITH?
>> WOW.
WHO HAS MORE POINTS?
MACKINNON SERIES OR MARCUS SMART
TOMORROW?
>> I'LL GO AND SAY MARCUS SMART.
I THINK MARCUS SMART CAN GET
PROBABLY CLOSE TO 20 POINTS
TOMORROW.
IF MACKINNON SCORES 15 POINTS,
THERE'S YOUR CONN SMYTHE.
>> IS THAT LIKE -- THAT'S -- SO
HE'S WINNING THE CONN SMYTHE IF
HE DOES THAT.
>> 100%.
THAT'S AN AMAZING SERIES.
THAT'S GOALS PLUS ASSISTS.
HE'S HAVING TWO PLUS GOALS EVERY
GAME OR TWO PLUS POINTS EVERY
GAME IF THAT HAPPENS.
I'LL GO WITH MARCUS SMART, BUT I
LOVE THAT HYPOTHETICAL.
WE NEED MORE OF THAT STUFF.
>> THAT'S A FUN BET.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GET ROLLING.
I THINK YOU TEASED EARLIER ABOUT
THE APP AND HOW WE ARE TAKING A
SQUAD RIDE FROM THE APP THAT
GAVE OUT THE LIGHTNING.
THERE'S ALSO, YOU KNOW, ONCE
YOU'RE FINISHED WITH THE SHOW,
THE COMMUNITY STREAM.
SHOUT OUT TO OUR APP FOLKS,
MICHAEL AND LOGAN FOR KEEPING
OUR APP COMMUNITY FLOWING.
SOMEONE GAVE OUT THE UNDER TODAY
IN THE APP.
WE'RE PULLING IT UP NOW.
RITTER, I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I WON'T READ THAT.
I APPRECIATE KEV.
I'M SURE -- A LOT OF WORDS.
MAX, THE PRODUCER OF THE SHOW
SENT ME AN ARTICLE TODAY, I SAID
MAKE A TIKTOK FOR IT, I'M NOT
READING THAT.
I'LL ASK YOU, UNDER, GOOD BET,
BAD BET?
YOUR TAKE?
>> THE KEV 87, TWO THUMBS UP ON
THIS PICK.
I WILL BE TAILING THIS TONIGHT.
IF YOU LIKE THE LIGHTNING, YOU
LIKE THE UNDER TONIGHT.
AGAIN, THIS IS GOING TO BE A BIG
SHOCK TO THE SYSTEM FOR THE
AVALANCHE RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
AGAIN, VASILEVSKIY WILL MAKE
STOPS.
THEY HAVE AMAZING OFFENSIVE
POWER AND WE FAILED TO MENTION
BRAYDEN POINT IS BACK TONIGHT
FOR THE LIGHTNING.
THAT ALSO PLAYS INTO MY PICK
TONIGHT.
THAT WAS AWESOME TO SEE BRAYDEN
POINT, ESPECIALLY A POSTSEASON
PLAYER.
YOU'RE A BIT CONCERNED WITH IT
BEING HIS FIRST GAME BACK, GAME
ONE OF THE STANLEY CUP FINALS,
HE'S JUST ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS IN THE NHL.
WE HAVE NIKITA KUCHEROV,
STAMKOS, PALAT.
I THINK THEY'LL HANG WITH THE
AVALANCHE.
I THINK THEY'LL WIN TONIGHT.
I DO WORRY A BIT IF YOU FIND
6.5.
DRAFTKINGS HAS IT AT 6.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THAT THE
AVALANCHE WIN 8-3 AND I LOOK
LIKE A COMPLETE IDIOT.
NOT THAT I DON'T LOOK LIKE A
COMPLETE IDIOT NOW WEARING THIS
COSTUMES.
IF THE AVS BLOW THEM OUT
TONIGHT, I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT IT AND I'LL DEFEND MYSELF
IN THE APP COMMUNITY FOR THIS
ONE.
LOVE THE UNDER TONIGHT.
>> LOVE THAT.
LOVE THE COMMUNITY VIBES.
RITTER, WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF
TIME.
I DO WANT TO TAKE SOME QUESTIONS
FROM THE CHAT, FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
I WANT A RAPID FIRE.
I WILL THROW SHIT AT YOU.
YOU TELL ME QUICK, YEA, NAY,
MOVE ON.
RAPID FIRE.
SO S, IS CALE MAKAR THE POWER PY
QB?
TAKE ON HIS TAKE?
>> I LOVE HIM.
CALE MAKAR, LOVE HIM.
AVALANCHE SCORE TONIGHT, THAT
CONFLICTS WITH THE UNDER IN MY
BET, BUT HE'S THE POWER PLAY GOD
IN MY OPINION.
IF YOU CAN FIND A 0.5 POWER PLAY
POINTS, HE WILL GET AN ASSIST.
THAT'S JUST HOW IT GOES.
>> ABELLA IS JUST GIVING US A
PICK.
GREAT VALUE, UNDER 2.5 SHOTS ON
GOAL FROM STAMKOS.
LOOKS WAY TOO EASY TO GO OVER.
BELIEVE ME, I'VE BEEN AROUND
THIS FOR OVER 35 YEARS.
YOUR TAKE ON THAT TAKE?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE TALKING
TO A SHARP.
SHARK.
MAYBE IT IS TOO EASY.
I WON'T STOP YOU THERE.
KEEP DROPPING THOSE PICKS.
AWESOME.
>> SOME MORE TAKES.
BOLTS IN FIVE, PLUS 1000.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT?
ARE YOU GOING TO MESS AROUND
WITH ANY OF THE EXACTOS?
>> I PROBABLY WON'T.
IF YOU'RE FEELING FRISKY, AGAIN,
THEY SWEPT THE PANTHERS WHO WERE
CONSIDERED THE BEST TEAM ALL
YEAR, WHO KNOWS.
PLUS 1000, FRISKY.
>> AND OUR FINAL QUESTION, WHICH
I TOUCHED ON EARLIER, BUT DIDN'T
GET A GOOD ANSWER FOR, THIS ONE
COMES FROM FAV.
JUST YOUR OVERALL TAKES ON THE
CALVIN COOLIDGE ADMINISTRATION,
WHAT DO YOU THINK WORKED AND
WHAT DID NOT WORK?
>> SO, HE WAS SILENT COW.
HE DIDN'T SPEAK UP ENOUGH.
WE NEED MORE VOCAL LEADERS.
>> DON'T BRING POLITICS INTO
THIS SHOW.
>> GIVE IT LIKE A C MINUS
ADMINISTRATION.
SORRY, CALVIN.
R.I.P., THOUGH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THAT WILL DO IT FOR US.
RITTER, RAPID FIRE, BEFORE WE
GO, YOUR SIX BETS, GIVE THEM TO
ME IN 30 SECONDS.
GO.
>> YOU'RE KIDDING.
IF ANYONE MISSED THE ELECTRIC
HALF HOUR, MACKINNON, OVER 2 1/2
GOALS.
VASILEVSKIY, CONN SMYTHE AWARD.
SERIES TO GO SEVEN GAMES, PLUS
210.
ANDREI VASILEVSKIY, OVER 32.5
SAVES TONIGHT.
LIGHTNING MONEYLINE, APP SQUAD
RIDE, AND THE GIFT, PLUS 100 AT
DRAFTKINGS.
THAT'S IT FOR ME.
GO LIGHTNING.
CAVS ARE FRAUDS.
AVS ARE FRAUDS.
>> THANKS FOR WATCHING.
PEACE.